Sonia is in Santa Cruz I Sonia welcome
to the Dave Ramsey show hello miss
around me how are you better than I
deserve
what's up and so I had a question last
year around August my mother because my
parents came to my house to me Oh taking
over well kind of taking over their
remaining mortgage balance or principal
and an equity loan that behind pink him
on the house because she got really sick
and she had to go into this ability and
she could no longer make the equity
payment some mortgage payment she ended
up passing away in December yeah
so now I have this house and I live with
my dad and I believe we're going to live
together forever I have took a single
mom what is the balance on my house
right now is three hundred and forty and
six thousand dollars and the value is
five hundred and ninety eight thousand
dollars and I'm wondering are we doing
sell the house or do we keep it I don't
know what to do I mean I can I've edited
I make about $43,000 a year
how are you playing the payment my dad
is receiving and benef severance
benefits
he receives about two thousand dollars a
month and I make I bring home about
twenty seven twenty eight hundred
dollars a month so you have forty seven
forty eight hundred dollars a month to
work with house payments are how much we
don't have any oh the house payments and
24:33 including insurance and taxes on
the house you need to sell the house we
need to call it
you cannot exist with the house payments
is fifty percent of your household
income yeah you're not you're just
barely holding on aren't you yeah very
highly stressful mm-hmm yeah I think the
only being as that
it's been our house or my mom's house so
it is very sad but you can't afford it I
mean there's no future here unless your
income is going to double soon I know I
believe something got an $800 increase
radius and January and we usually get a
$5,000 bonus during the year : I'm 35
hmm how's your dad's health he's very
healthy how old is he 6 26 161 yes and
he receives a benefit survivor what does
he make a year working he doesn't work
you spent the last three years taking
care of my mom okay and she passed away
in December I'm sorry you guys are
facing this he needs to go to work yeah
mal okay this is May y'all are starvin
to that yeah we don't really have a lot
of fun we just pay the bills you can't
even pay your bills hardly you're
starving to death well I also receive
$500 a month in child support I have it
that's sweet honey but your house mem is
50% of your household income because
your father's when I gotten reemployed
yeah he needs to get re-employed and you
know probably need to sell the house the
house was deeded over to you yeah it was
and since it was from a parent to a
child I believe the taxes will never
change on it you know the property taxes
won't change but that you've got all
kinds of tax problems with the income
tax because they did not do it properly
so you you very likely your dad could
get hammered for about 30 or 40 thousand
dollars worth of income tax called gift
tax because they didn't do this and you
have another problem and that is that
the mortgages that you just took over do
not allow you to do that
[Music]
and they have the right to call those
loans at any time to start foreclosure
you can't just take over someone's
mortgages without the bank's permission
and they do not give permission to take
over mortgages without qualification and
you did not qualify for these mortgages
I mean everything's under I'm the
borrower I am the money I mean
everything's under my name the mortgages
did not transfer to your name no they
didn't because they would have called
them if they figure out that this has
happened they have the right they may
not choose to but they have the right to
call the loan in full so you guys are in
a world of hurt here so here's a couple
things to do and I'm gonna try to get
the stress off of you as best I can that
you guys getting hammered you you need
to call you need to go to Dave Ramsey
calm and do two things one is click on
ELP for real estate and talk to some
real estate agents and let's get this
house on the market before you get in
trouble and lose it it's got too much
equity for you to lose the second thing
that needs to happen is you need to
click on ELP endorse local provider for
taxes and you guys need to sit down with
a tax professional and go file an
amended return for your parents income
taxes last year immediately with a gift
tax under the you got pencil yeah under
the unified estate tax credit and that
way your dad and mom can transfer this
much equity to you without having gift
tax but it has to be done with a form if
you come along and the IRS audits them
four years from now this has not been
done it'll be taxed all of that equity
would be taxed at fifty five percent
I'm talking about federal not California
oh you're gonna get a hammer he's gonna
get hammered so you got and it's one
form and you know a little bit of work
to do this properly so I would get the
house on the market I'm afraid the
mortgages are gonna be called and you
guys can't afford it and I know it's a
had it I'm so sorry you're facing this
honey
but you're going to make some big girl
decisions because you're in a big girl
mess okay
and so get the taxes done with a tax
professional it's called the unified
estate tax credit get an amended return
filed immediately and then let's start
talking to a real estate agent about
getting this thing on the market and
then let's lay out a game plan for our
future of how we're going to eat and
that is including your daddy going back
to work now okay okay because your
family can't make it in Santa Cruz
California the cost of living is too
high with what you guys have coming in
without him working yeah am I wrong no
you're not okay I'm not trying to be
harsh with you and just want to be I
just want to speak real clearly to you
because I don't want any more pain in
your life you've had enough pain you
okay yeah now have you ever been through
Financial Peace University no you want
to go through as my guest and learn how
to handle money and take your dad with
you yes please
okay good and so you hold on and I'll
have Kelly pick up and we'll get you
signed up for that and then you call me
if you need any help as you go along I
don't want you to get stunned here kiddo
you guys have had enough pain or the
loss of your mom and all the stuff of
him taking care of her and everything
else it's just too much it's just too
much to bear and we'll help you carry it
but you're gonna have to make some big
girl decisions and they're hard to do
it's hard to do but you're not left with
a lot of options here so this will give
you motivation for cleaning up your life
and your finances and getting on a plan
that's sustainable meaning you can pay
the bills because you can't make it when
your house payments 50% of your
take-home pay it's just I mean you make
it a short term but you just can't
prosper with that so hey hold on Kelly
I'll pick up and we'll take care of you